so in the early days you know you were
just a college dropout
you were very young-looking did you get
taken seriously by businessmen who are
much older for some people that youth ah
and geekiness was like eh should we
trust them you know that's so weird
we've never seen something like that
before so yes we had to fight for
acceptance I couldn't rent cars so I had
to take cabs around because I was too
young and you know probably some people
were a little tough but then as we got a
little bit of success people were
fascinated by this deep belief we had in
in software okay so when Microsoft is
moving forward you decide to take the
company public in 1986 six and at that
point you are a billionaire I also every
close to it within a year of going
public I think there's some important
cover that says the deal that made Bill
Gates 360 million or some weird thing
like that all right how did it change
your life or it didn't change your life
at all well that whole period of time
was amazing because I was hiring people
as fast as I could
I had brought in Steve Ballmer who was
very good at that and and he was helping
out you know we had a sense of urgency
that we wanted to lead the way there was
this graphics interface thing with
Windows that we wanted to do so I was
super busy and the idea that I could
hire so quickly and invest and build
this worldwide company it was
fascinating to me